قالت صحيفه هارتس الاسرائيليه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اصبح بالفعل في خضم الانتشار
للمرحله الثالثه على عكس ما يعلنه صناع
القرار مضيفه ان مراكز القياده المختلفه
تستعد بالفعل لتغيير كبير في يناير المقبل
وان الجيش الاسرائيلي يخطط لتسريح عدد من
جنود الاحتياط واضافت الصحيفه الاسرائيليه
ان التغييرات مرتبطه باعاده انتشار مئات
الاف جنود الاحتياط بسبب العبئ على
الاقتصاد وعلى الجنود وعائلتهم واوضحت
هارتس ان التعديلات المرتقبه تشمل انشاء
منطقه عازله داخل منطقه قطاع غزه لكن
الجدول الزمنيه المرتبطه بها سيكون مرنا
وذلك لاعتبارات نتنياهو السياسيه معتبره
ان الوضع على الارض لا يتقدم بالوتير التي
نسمعها في الخطاب السياسي في حين قالت
القناه الحاديه عش الاسرائيليه ان الجيش
يستعد لانهاء العمليه البريه في غضون اس
سبيع مؤكده ان المرحله الثالثه تشمل تقليص
عدد القوات وتشكيل منطقه عازله والاستمرار
في هجمات
مركزه لمتابعه ذلك معنا من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره احمد هزيم احمد هل ثم يعني
تاكيدات ردود فعل ااء هذه المعلومات
الصحفيه نشوان حتى اللحظه ليس هناك اي
ردود فعل مميزه حول هذا ما حول ما نشر في
وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه عن الدخول او
الاستعداد للدخول الى المرحله الثالثه سوى
الحديث في وسائل الاعلام امريكيه عن
التناقض بين ما ينشره الجيش الاسرائيلي
وما تنشره او ما يتحدث به المسؤولون
واعضاء في حكومه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وتحديدا رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو
وايضا اقطاب اليمين المتشدد الذين يدفعون
في جميع ما يصرحون به الى مزيد
من العمليات العسكريه للاستمرار في هذه
الكثافه ضمن العمليات العسكريه وتدمير
القطاع باكمله اذا اذا اخذنا ما يقال على
لسان بنفير او سموتريتش
لكن ما نشره الجيش هو ما ربما كان يتفاوض
او يدفع
باتجاهه المسؤولين الامريكيين الذين زاروا
تل ابيب والقدس في الايام القليله او
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه اذا تحدثنا عن
مستشار الرئيس الامريكي للامن القومي جاك
سوليفان او حتى وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد
اوستن والذين تحدثوا عن ضروره الدخول الى
مرحله اخرى في العمليات البريه وهي مرحله
يطالب الجانب الامريكي بان تتضمن منطقه
امنه للمدنيين وربما هنا الحديث عن تقسيم
قطاع غزه الى ثلاث ثلاثه مناطق عسكريه
المنطقه الاولى سيطره عسكريه وامنيه للجيش
الاسرائيلي المنطقه الثانيه ان يكون للجيش
الاسرائيلي وقوات الامن الاسرائيليه اليد
الطوله في تنفيذ عمليات محدوده ونوعيه
ومنطقه ثالثه تكون منطقه امنه يدعى اليها
المدنيون الغزاويين لكن حتى اللحظه ليس
هناك وضوح حول مناطق او هذه التقسيمات
خصوصا في ظل هذا التناقض بين الجانب
السياسي والجانب العسكري الجيش يسرب هذه
المعلومات الى وسائل اعلام امريكيه لتكون
حاضره في النقاش المحلي الاسرائيلي خصوصا
في ظل التصريحات التي استمعنا اليها
بالامس من رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
والذي قال فيها بان المعركه ستمر وانه
يطرح امام حركه وقاده حركه حماس خيارين لا
ثالث لهما هما ام القتل او الاستسلام
ولقائه باسر الجنود القتلى في غزه وايضا
تعهده امامهم بان الحرب ستستمر كما هي حتى
القضاء على حركه حماس وتفكيك بنيتها
العسكريه وبنيتها التحتيه الجيش ربما سرب
هذه المعلومات القول بان هناك جدول
عملياتي للجيش الاسرائيلي يختلف عن
الاغراض السياسيه والحاجات
السياسيه لبنيامين نتنياهو واعضاء من
حكومته وان الطريق الان امام الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو الانتهاء من هذه المرحله اي
المرحله الثانيه اي العمليات البريه
والدخول الى المرحله الثالثه كما هو يطالب
به الجانب الامريكي وهو الاكثر دعما الى
اسرائيل الان ياتي
ستكون الايام المقبله مليئه بالحديث عن ما
هو ما كيف ستتعامل القياده السياسيه مع
هذه التسريبات كيف سيسال السياسيون
الاسرائيليون عن هذه التسريبات وما هي
الشروط او الاهداف التي يجب تحقيقها خلال
الاسابيع المقبله لكي تكون اسرائيل مستعده
للدخول الى المرحله الثالثه هناك بعد اخر
ايضا نشوان وهو بعد تسريح العشرات وربما
مئات الالاف من الجنود الاحتياط الذين تم
استدعائهم للدخول في هذه الحرب وهم قرابه
360,000 جندي هذا هؤلاء هم عمال وموظفون
اخذوا من العجله الاقتصاديه والخسائر
الاقتصاديه للجانب الاسرائيلي هي خسائر
كبيره للغايه لا تستطيع تحملها وربما ياتي
هذا القرار ايضا اخذ في الاعتبار الحاجه
لاعاده تدوير العجله الاقتصاديه
الاسرائيليه خصوصا في ظل ان الخسائر
الاقتصاديه خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالمواصلات
ومطار بنورين مثلا الذي
تقريبا خارج عن الخدمه فقط شركه طيران
العالي الاسرائيليه وشركه اخرى هي من يسير
رحلات من هذا المطار بقيه الشركات الطيران
قد انهت او اوقفت رحلاتها 1000 من موظفيها
هذا المطار تم تم تقليص رواتبهم و600
تم اخطارهم بالبقاء في المنزل دون رواتب
كلها هذا فقط مثال صغير على حجم الخسائر
التي يعانيها الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي من هذه
الحرب وربما ياتي ال تاخ يؤخذ في الاعتبار
هذا عندما يتم القرار او يتخذ القرار
بالدخول الى المرحله الثالثه